a growing push by airline employees
their unions and even airline executives
to include additional federal aid in the
next coronavirus relief package
without it they say tens of thousands of
workers could lose their jobs
just a month before the presidential
election many of them in swing states
cbs news transportation correspondent
chris van cleeve spoke with southwest
airlines ceo gary kelly
about the plight of the nation's
airlines
united flight attendant yolanda hughes
is among the more than 82 thousand
airline employees
cbs news has learned have been told they
could be furloughed as soon as october
first when the government's payroll
support program runs out
it's almost like watching something that
you've been a part of
that you've helped build kind of fall
apart or
crumble and you don't have anything else
to do
other than just stand aside and feel
helpless
but help could come from capitol hill
members of the house and 16 senate
republicans have now signed letters
calling for another 25 billion in
payroll support for airlines
to avoid job cuts until at least next
march
we're very grateful for the support that
we've had southwest airlines ceo gary
kelly
what's in it for the taxpayer to keep
airline workers working when so many
other industries don't get that kind of
help
just very clear that absent some
continued support you will see
massive layoffs in october you'll see
massive
service cuts and that simply means that
all the money
that was invested so far to sustain
the airline industry will be for naught
he's promised his employees no furloughs
or layoffs in 2020
but says passenger traffic needs to
double to avoid them next year
additional government support would buy
time while business remains off by 75
percent
something kelly doesn't see rebounding
much until there's a vaccine
we have not found a restructuring plan
to be able to survive
at 25 percent a new survey found
passengers worry more about catching
covid during flying than in their daily
lives and 84 percent of leisure flyers
have not booked a trip this summer the
thing they say is most important for an
airline to do
is thoroughly cleaning the cabin seats
and tray tables
just this week southwest announced it
was reducing cleanings between flights
to focus on tray tables
and the bathrooms why back off that kind
of cleaning right now
we just determined that the time that it
took to try to do
all surfaces wasn't adding any value
touch surfaces like arm rests and seat
belts will now be disinfected as part of
a nightly deep cleaning of all aircraft
the carrier also uses electrostatic
foggers to spray a disinfecting mist
that can kill
virus and bacteria for up to 90 days
part of a new normal in very uncertain
skies
we will get passes we will do what we
have to do for southwest airlines to
survive
for cbs this morning saturday chris van
cleave
washington not the first emergency for
the airlines but certainly a very bad
one
yeah no matter how much cleaning they do
there's still a risk yeah and
weigh all those risks before you end up
booking those flights and continue to
travel in the future we will see